i got to give them credit these party
conventions are not
great tv they usually are pretty tone
deaf about what's going on
in the country but they made one really
excellent pick
at the republican national convention
they chose to have the covington kid
come out and speak not some polished
politician not some activist whose name
we've known forever
it's that kid who was wearing the maga
hat at the national mall
he was right in front of the lincoln
memorial and he
he was just standing there at pro-life
rally this crazy native american man
comes and starts banging a drum
in his face a group of black
supremacists called the hebrew
israelites were shouting all sorts of
terrible names
and the mainstream media decided to try
to ruin this kid's reputation
destroy his life pounce on him all of
the above
now actually this kid sued cnn he sued
the washington post he sued other news
organizations
so far cnn and washington post have
settled because they knew that he was
in the right so the rnc gets nick
sandman to start speaking in front of
the lincoln memorial where it all
started
on the power and the corruption of the
mainstream media
well the media portrayed me as an
aggressor with a relentless
smirk on my face in reality the video
confirms i was standing with my hands
behind my back
and an awkward smile on my face that had
two thoughts
one don't do anything that might further
agitate the man banging a drum
in my face and two i was trying to
follow a family friend's advice
never to do anything to embarrass your
family
your school or your community
before i knew what was happening it was
over
one of mr phillips fellow agitators
yelled out
we got him it's all right here on video
and we won grandpa what i thought was a
strange encounter
quickly developed into a major news
story complete with video footage
my life changed forever in that one
moment
the full war machine of the mainstream
media revved up into attack mode
they did so without researching the full
video of the incident
without ever investigating mr phillips
motives
or without ever asking me for my side of
the story
and do you know why because the truth
was not important because the truth was
not
important this is something we've been
saying on this show now for well for a
very long time but
in recent memory over the past few days
which is it's not that the mainstream
media
intentionally lie all the time it's not
that the mainstream media
want to invert the truth all the time
though sometimes they do
it's that the mainstream media don't
care about the truth
they don't care the truth is completely
irrelevant
to what the mainstream media do it's not
that they're
constant liars it's that they're cynics
they think
the truth doesn't matter they are there
to propagandize for the democratic party
and so are the protests violent or not
violent doesn't matter move the chiron
around who cares
what makes us look good which is the
best way to position us whoops sorry we
left that word violent in there can't do
that
that's what nick sandman saw and he goes
on to make a pretty interesting point
there
he says that what we've been seeing all
around the country
is a media that is pushing
anti-trump anti-conservative
and anti-christian narratives don't
forget this is a catholic high school
student
who was attacked because he was at the
march for life there is a bit of a
christian element here too
and i think this was so brilliant i mean
i think this guy has a lot of political
clarity and vision here
which is all of these issues that we're
talking about are not just the surface
level issues
they go down much deeper to use the
specific example of wisconsin
this is not just about the shooting of
some black man who had a warrant out for
his arrest for sexual assault and
domestic abuse who was reaching into a
truck
it's not just about that why was it in
wisconsin
why is it happening right now why is
this being popularized by the media
because it has a political angle to it
because the democrats and the left
believe that this will help them
win the election same thing with the
mail-in ballots why is the left suddenly
the great champion of the post office
and and trying to get everybody to mail
in their
votes the the cdc dr fauci all these
people say we can vote in person
so why are the democrats trying to keep
people from voting in person
don't the democrats want people to vote
no the democrats just want people's
votes
so the easiest way they can collect
people's votes is by having them stay
home
mail them in and then they can implement
their corrupt
voter fraud schemes that they've
implemented many other times in many
other places around the country
including recently in new jersey
it goes down a little bit of a level
deeper you've got to see through the
news and what sandman is seeing is
it doesn't just stop at the political
level it has a cultural level too and
ultimately
it has a religious quality because as
henry edward cardinal manning one of our
favorite guys to quote on this show is
he says
at bottom all human conflict is
ultimately
theological i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you